what do you know so tonight I'm hosting
a slumber party for a few guys around
the office because they've never had a
slumber party before and they seem
pretty clueless pillow fights that's a
thing right pillow fights for sure
yeah no pillow fights are not a thing
I've come up for a few activities for
them so I hope they're excited not very
excited I'm so down
so I'm sitting here and it's been legit
almost an hour I have no clue what they
could be doing oh yeah for sure oh yeah
for sure
Jasmine what are we gonna be doing first
you guys are going to be applying face
masks to each other
don't shake my head to no sleep I lost a
cucumber you kind of terrifying look
you're supposed to try and relax go no
just relax buddy more with your fingers
I'm going to I'm just squeezing it all
out first oh I got some on your onesie
too by the way let me take off my face
whoa dude it's like peeling a plastic
off of a new iPhone you're the new
iPhone I'm the new iPhone so I'm
deciding on having them do a two-minute
manicure because it is the hardest thing
to do and I also think it's even harder
painting someone else's fingernails I
look really good in green but I also
like the color purple do you want to do
both let's do both and stop how's your
family
Emily's great can't wait for them to see
this video Kenny you're gonna look
fabulous thank you
this ring finger looks like it's doing a
walk of shame I did a pretty good job
with you am I wrong no absolutely not it
was horrible I had the worst set of
nails at the entire party the third
activity will be pillow talk I'm having
them do pillow talk because I feel like
it's a good activity for everyone to
like open up with each other we've only
seen each other like around the office
and a little downtime afterwards so this
will be really good to like dig in there
so where do you guys see yourself in
like five years I don't like thinking
about I don't even know where I'm gonna
be next year I would like to think that
I would be working at least someplace
where I'm telling so
you know I mean that's why I move down
here so my end game really is to just
make enough money to support myself and
my family doing what I love to do are
you planning on being married in five
years I don't know if I'll be married in
five years but when do you think you'd
want to get married really late 20s to
early 30s I don't see myself later like
mid mid to late thirties I feel like I
would be okay with getting married like
late 20s but then but then waiting to
have kids so that I could travel there's
a lot of things that we unfortunately
have to let go as you get older so as an
adult to be able to just pick a night of
the week and just put on a onesie as
silly as that all sounds it's incredibly
gratifying should we do this again I'd
be down for that also if it's a larger
slumber party maybe like seven to ten
people that many people could build a
dope-ass for oh man we should have built
a fort